bruno le maire est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce dernier rendez-vous de
la saison avant de nous retrouver bien
sûr à la rentrée alors pas de vacances
pour pour vous j'imagine bruno le maire
est encore en vous restez sur le terrain
tout l'été je vais quand même prendre un
jour au pays basque
quand même 15 ou alors trois grandes
questions pour vous au cours de cette
émission premièrement qu'attendez-vous
de françois hollande le 14 juillet
deuxième question la primaire dont vous
êtes aujourd'hui la outsiders blocs
telle en fait tous renouveau c'est votre
rythme motif d'un véhicule jacques de
l'aspect vous interrogera sur ce grand
rendez vous de novembre
enfin troisième question josé manuel
barroso at il commis une faute contre
l'europe
l'ancien président de la commission en
effet accepté de rejoindre la banque
américaine goldman sachs et vous
répondrez à appliquer la baisse de
public sénat qui vous interrogera
également sur les questions de défense
puisque vous avez annoncé vos
propositions ces derniers jours dernier
14-juillet du quinquennat donc qu
attendez vous qu'espérez vous de
françois hollande
très franchement plus grand chose plus
grand chose donc c'est pour ça que cette
primaire qui vient de la droite et du
centre est aussi importante à mes yeux
c'est que c'est l'occasion de recréer un
espoir pour les français pour dire voilà
nous arrivons chacun avec nos projets
notre vision de la france
nos idées et notre méthode de
gouvernement
mais le chef de l'état il a encore des
choses à dire vous avez l'écouté car oui
il aurait janvier je suis pas sûr de
l'écouté très franchement non non parce
que voilà j'estime que il a menti il a
trompé les français
il n'a pas présenté de vision pas
présenté de cap et que ce quinquennat
est un gigantesque gâchis est donc très
franchement je vous le dis moi j'estime
avoir mieux à faire que d'écouter des
paroles concrète des paroles des paroles
des paroles puis derrière pas de
décisions pas d'acte pas de vision du
pays
il reste onze mois à peu près au pouvoir
et j'espère bien que en mai prochain
mais 2017
mais nous aurons un autre président dans
tous les cas ils pourraient le chef de
l'état encore filer la métaphore
sportive il l'a fait un peu avant la
finale de l'euro la france a du ressort
elle sait se rassembler on l'a vu contre
ceux qui ne parlent que de ce qui ne
marche pas entre déni et repli ça c'est
pour les leaders de la droite mort fin
c'est à l'équipe de france qu'on doit
d'avoir connu quelques semaines
merveilleuses vous offert beaucoup de
moments de bonheur c'est pas à françois
hollande
cette façon de récupérer
systématiquement le foot le sport enfin
laissons les sportifs nos amis
footballeurs l'équipe de france là où
elles sont ils nous ont offert
d'excellents moments
mais après il ya la situation de la
france qui reste difficile et d'autres
responsabilités à nous politiques s'est
pas défilé des bêtas fort toujours un
peu douteuse avec le sport et avec
l'euro de foot c'est de dire voilà les
difficultés des français
voilà les réponses de j apporte et voilà
la parole que je veux tenir pour que ça
marche mieux d'entreprises dont quand
vous comprends vous ne croyez pas oh ça
va mieux pourtant il a quand même gagné
semble-t-il en crédibilité depuis que
françois hollande a lancé la formule je
vous propose d'écouter l'économiste de
la fce eric heyer pour s'aperçoit que la
croissance s'accélère que les déficits
sont plus faibles que prévu et même plus
faible que les années précédentes on
s'aperçoit que les créations d'emplois
sont dynamiques aujourd'hui que le
chômage baisse donc oui le considérer
que ça va mieux mais attention le ça va
mieux
voyez quand vous dites ça à votre ami ça
va mieux c'est que vous êtes malade et
c'est à dire que sinon vous dites ça va
bien effectivement faut faire attention
avec des nuances entre ça va mieux ça va
bien c'est que on est encore mal a alors
la france souffre toujours bien sûr
bruno le maire mais ça va mieux
chaque bonne nouvelle vous savez
ailleurs d'esprit positif
je l'accueille avec beaucoup de plaisir
dès qu'il ya un chômeur en moins
demandeurs d'emploi en moins je le
premier à me réjouir
enfin je vois à inverser la corée
chômage sur la fin du quinquennat on est
bien d'accord mais c'est pas ce qui
compte ce qui compte c'est pas de se
limiter à g inverser la courbe du
chômage et réussi après avoir créé des
centaines de milliers de chômeurs
supplémentaires
finalement inversé la cour enfin ça ça
change pas la situation concrète les
millions de français qui cherchent un
emploi des familles qui s'inquiètent de
ce qu ont plus de 50 ans comptait
licencier et qui retrouve plus rien
l'enjeu n'est pas là l'enjeu c'est de
retrouver un élan pour notre pays
l'indulgence vohra d'indulgence pour
françois copé et jean il est chef de
l'état c'est celui qui a le droit au
moindre indulgence parce que c'est celui
qui a la fonction la plus élevée donc la
responsabilité la plus élevée alors la
facture sécuritaire mais également celle
des aides
diverses aux agriculteurs aux jeunes aux
collectivités locales également été mise
en avant récemment pour expliquer
l'abandon du plan de 50 milliards
d'euros d'économies
est ce le signe pour vous d'un manque de
sérieux budgétaire un sérieux qui est
pourtant revendiqué avec force par les
ministres de bercy notamment michel
sapin je crois surtout que c'est le
signal que à quelques mois d'élections
présidentielles on ouvre tout grand les
vannes de la dépense publique pour
essayer d'acheter les votes de quelques
catégories de la population
moi je suis persuadé que les français
quel qu'il soit ne se laisseront pas
trompés par ce genre de décision
politique après serait du champ aux
dépenses publiques ce qui compte c'est
le sérieux avec lequel on fait ça c'est
l'honnêteté de ses engagements
dire que l'on va tenir parole et que sur
un calendrier de cinq ans on va tenir sa
ligne de réduction des déficits
mais il s'agit pas de vouloir tailler le
plus possible à l'aveuglé en réponse qui
va vous être contre la résurgence jeu
contre la purge est propre à la burj
fait bien de le rappeler c'est
exactement ça j'arrête la purge
c'est dangereux et puis ça nous
interdire sauf que c'est parce qu'il a
annoncé moi je préfère annoncer la
couleur tout de suite je serai rigoureux
dans la réduction des dépenses publiques
je tiendrai mon calendrier et mes
engagements mais je ne veux pas imposer
de purges au française que je pense que
c'est pas une bonne solution parce que
je pense que ça menaceraient la
croissance
et parce que je pense aussi je les dis à
quelques jours qu'il faut que nous
investissions dans deux domaines majeurs
la justice et les forces en va en parler
mais alors quand vous dites ça pas de
purge de la pâture enchères dans la
dépense vous pensez à qui est donc plus
à françois hollande mais revault à vos
concurrents de la primaire dont 15 juin
sa personne mais je vois que certains
avancent en essayant 120 130 agents des
familles pour dire ce qu'on était
capable de faire du dernier quinquennat
faisons attention pas faire des
promesses en l'air personne n'y croira
clan alors est-ce que la france
néanmoins mérite selon vous va être visé
par une procédure pour déficit excessif
à l'instar par exemple de ce qui se
passe en ce moment même à l'encontre du
portugal et d'espagne
je crois pas que ce soit la situation
actuelle c'est à la commission
européenne d'en juger
moi je compte une fois encore c'est le
respect de nos engagements qu'on puisse
dire aux français mais aussi à nos
partenaires européens
voilà mon calendrier de réduction des
dépenses publiques et je m'y tiendrai
pour une fois on trompe pas les rats
quand tous les cas on l'a vu ces
derniers mois ses terres
rené la france l'a à bénéficier d'une
grande mansuétude de bruxelles
même si comme le disait jean claude
juncker justement congrès des maires de
france récemment que la france est la
france
écoute france doit continuer son
assainissement est budgétée la france
doit absolument être en dessous des 3%
en 2010 à des plus nous verrons à la
france je ne cesse de donner des
dérogations
il faut savoir sortir des dérogations à
jour et vous seriez prêt au corps a
donné quelques dérogations d'ici 2017
maintenant tout est balisé en vue de la
performance qui consiste à tomber en
dessous des 3 % en 2017
vous dites je ne cesse de donner des
dérogations à la france pourquoi parce
que c'est la france vient de rencontrer
jean claude juncker à bruxelles il ya
quelques jours et je lui ai dit voilà
quelle est la vision que je développe
pour mon pays où il faut tenir nos
engagements budgétaires bien sûr ce que
promet aujourd'hui ben c'est pas ce qui
compte le plus ce qui compte le plus
c'est que nous arrivions à refonder
notre pays et c'est ça l'enjeu de 2017
et vous a dit ah oui vous êtes français
et celle des français non il est gay
peut-être un peu moins tolérants
justement en face à face et je lui dis
moi mon ambition c'est pas de ta voir le
fétichisme du chiffre c'est que ça aille
mieux pour les français et donc on
construise un modèle économique un
modèle social un modèle politique qui
soit plus efficace et plus juste sur le
plan du ce sur le plan budgétaire est ce
qu'on peut un peu plus se lâcher
aujourd'hui même si on a plus de 2000
milliards de dette avec des taux
d'intérêt on le voit qu'ils sont
quasiment négatif pour la france est ce
que ça fait une incitation finalement à
ce qu'est ce qu'on a fait et ce qu'on
fait michel grossiord le jour les taux
d'intérêt remontent être un chef d'état
ou un homme d'état c'est anticiper un
renversement la conjoncture sans
anticiper des temps plus difficiles
le jour les taux d'intérêt remontent la
charge de la dette devient insupportable
pour les générations suivantes
moi je prendrais pas le risque de faire
peser sur mes enfants et demain mes
petits enfants
la charge de dépenses qui auraient été
faites pour nous aujourd'hui par pur
égoïsme
je pense que c'est totalement
irresponsable à propos justement d'échec
sur le futur dans l'actualité il ya
également le satisfecit
gouvernement sur les comptes de la
retraite puisque ça va mieux dans les
caisses apparemment même si le déficit
est encore très très lourd et on entend
marisol touraine dire que dans ce
contexte toutes nouvelles mesures d'âge
donc tout recul de l'âge de départ n'est
pas justifiée alors que vous justement
irresponsable irresponsable cette
déclaration de marisol touraine enfin on
a fait beaucoup dans le même sens mais
vraiment irresponsable parce que c'est
cacher une nouvelle fois aux français la
nécessité de passer à autre chose c'est
tout ce que je porte qu'en 2017
on passe vraiment autre chose notre
système de retraite nous n'est pas
finançable en d'état et non il est pas
juste moi je veut reporter l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite à 65 ans pour
tenir compte de l'allongement de la
durée de vie des français je veux
surtout que on aligne les règles de
cotisation des régimes publics sur les
régimes privés enfin personne ne
comprend cette inéquité entre régimes
publics et régimes privés alors on
tiendra compte bien entendu de la
réalité des rémunérations des
fonctionnaires la question des primes
mais il faut qu'il ait quitté la justice
et les mêmes régimes pour chacun je veux
qu'on supprime tous les régimes spéciaux
de retraite y compris y compris pour les
députés et pour les sénateurs et je veux
qu'on a un système par points
parce que je pense que c'est ce qu'il y
à aujourd'hui de plus transparente et
plus visible pour les français donc dire
attendez ça va mieux vaut plus rien
toucher sur le système de retraites
c'est irresponsable c'est le contraire
de ce que je veux porter une question
euro fort rentable qu'un 86 8 5 % de
réussite au bac cette année plus de 87%
pour le brevet que vous inspirent ces
chiffres varient de dévalorisation du
baccalauréat et ça m'inquiète parce que
je pense qu'on risque de tromper
beaucoup de français alors disons voilà
tout le monde d'avoir le baccalauréat
essaiera bien pour tout le monde
je pense qu'il faut qu'on change
d'objectif pour l'éducation nationale
l'objectif c'est plus 80 % d'une classe
d'âge au baccalauréat il est déjà
atteint cet objectif
l'objectif d'éducation nationale ça doit
être 100 % d'une classe d'âge avec un
emploi c'est un autre objectif qui
permettra de revaloriser la voie
professionnelle de développer
l'apprentissage de reconnaître
l'intelligence de chacun
nous avons un système éducatif et ses 88
% le dise qui est totalement monocorde
tout le monde dans la même direction
tout le monde dans la voie générale tout
le monde va l'université et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des gosses condos
d'intelligent d'autres talents moi je
veux une école qui reconnaissent tous
les talents et toutes les intelligences
elle
ministre à propos du bac considère qu'il
faut le simplifier et qui a trop
d'épreuves trop d'options vous êtes
d'accord sur ce point là je serais
d'accord et je serais d'accord ou encore
le niveau pour que l'on tienne compte du
contrôle continu davantage ma colère
parce que je crois que c'est une
question de justice
il ya des gamins qui peuvent perdre
leurs moyens au moment de l'examen s'ils
ont beaucoup travaillé pendant toute
l'année qui sont des bons résultats
scolaires toute l'année j'aimerais qu'on
en tienne davantage compte annonce par
ailleurs des embauches dans l'éducation
nationale elle se félicite que les
choses aillent mieux notamment au niveau
des recrutements de profs que sanyo sous
la gauche on écoute début du quinquennat
on a eu en effet du mal à pourvoir les
postes qu'on ouvrait il faut pas s'en
étonner parce que nous arrivions après
des années d'assèchement de l'éducation
souvenez-vous les 80000 post qui avait
été supprimée par la droite le fait
qu'on avait fait disparaître la
formation des enseignants qu'on avait
gelé les salaires des enseignants tout
ça avait envoyé des signaux très négatif
allez à l'attention des étudiants que
des études d'enseignants aurait pu
intéresser il a fallu bien deux trois
ans pour que enfin les jeunes gens
entendent cet appel de notre part est
aujourd'hui plus de deux ans en
particulier les concours font le plein
et donc les 60000 postes dans
l'éducation que françois hollande avait
promis en début de quinquennat seront
tenues d'ici la fin du quinquennat
voilà vous l'entendez en matière
éducative ça va vraiment mieux depuis le
début du quinquennat de françois je
considère que najat vallaud belkacem a
fait beaucoup de mal à l'éducation
nationale française beaucoup de matches
il a fait beaucoup de mal parce que elle
a supprimé le mérite en supprimant les
bourses au mérite
elle a fait beaucoup de mal en nivelant
par le bas et en supprimant ce qui
marchait par exemple les classes
bilangues elle a fait beaucoup de mal en
développement l'égalitarisme zend et
tout le monde doit avoir deux langues
étrangères au collège en cinquième alors
qu'on sait que des dizaines de milliers
de gamins qui rentrent en sixième sans
parler correctement le français elle a
fait beaucoup de mal
en nous disant qu'il fallait que les
enfants apprennent l'arabe au cp moi je
considère qu'en france dans l'école de
la république c'est la langue française
que l'on apprend au cpl a fait beaucoup
de mal en prêchant pour des recrutements
tous azimuts alors que je maintiens que
aujourd'hui on continue à avoir du mal à
recruter des enseignants de qualité de
bon niveau et qu'on dévalorise les
enseignants qui sont actuellement
poste en recrutant d'autres enseignants
qui n'ont pas forcément le même niveau
et je pense que fondamentalement ce
développement de la culture de
l'égalitarisme du nivellement par le bas
cette révision des programmes d'histoire
la manière qu'elle a eue de supprimer l'
apprentissage sérieux du latin zéro
pointé pour moi c'est un zéro pointé
je pense vraiment sincèrement plus
profond de moi-même que najat vallaud
belkacem a fait beaucoup de mal à
l'éducation nationale française et que
l'un des défis pour nous quand nous
reprendrons le pouvoir en 2017 ce sera
de restaurer le mérite
l'apprentissage de la langue française
la chronologie dans l'histoire un
collège diversifié plutôt qu'un collège
unique
le refus du nivellement par le bas et de
l'égalitarisme au bénéfice du mérite
c'est un enjeu majeur pour 2010
vous avez été ministre d'agriculture une
polémique se développe en ce moment
autour de la nomination possible du
directeur de cabinet de stéphane le foll
à la tête de l'inra monsieur philippe
mauguin est ce que vous êtes vous même
choqué par cette perspective là je
demande à françois hollande de renoncer
à cette nomination
l'inra c'est un des instituts de
recherche agronomique les plus pointus
les plus prestigieux au monde une bonne
procédure de nomination serait non pas
le fait du prince comme c'est le cas
actuellement à mini schiro case son
premier collaborateur
mais le processus de nomination dans
lequel on aurait un appel à candidature
avec des projets clairement défini
scientifique des projets de
développement de l'inra ou un collège
d'experts pourrait donner son avis y
compris d'ailleurs avec des experts
internationaux ce que je pense que pour
un organisme aussi prestigieux que
l'inra ce serait bien d'avoir un regard
international et qu'à la fin le meilleur
projet le meilleur candidat soit retenue
mais le fait du prince en matière de
domination ça me choque profondément
je souhaite que françois hollande
renonce à cette nomination qui fait
honte à la république et qui de la part
d'un président de la république qui
avait dit que sa présidence serait
exemplaire est un nouveau monument
c'est une tâche ce sera une tâche si
c'était fait ce serait une tâche par
rapport aux engagements qu'a pris
françois hollande qui nous avait dit
pendant le discours de bourget puis
pendant toute sa campagne de 2012 je
serai un président qui rétablira la
république exemplaire le fait du prince
dans les nominations ce n'est pas la
république exemplaire
une question sur emmanuel macron bien
sûr qui est en meeting ce soir à paris
monté sur une estrade doit-il selon vous
l'amener à quitter le gouvernement et au
plus vite
il fera son show dans tout cas il faut
qu'ils tranchent un moment donné en
politique il faut tronche à l'un et
l'autre c'est pas l'un des lots c'est
pas le gouvernement et la campagne la
campagne et le gouvernement
c'est l'un ou l'autre à lui 30 noms mais
est-ce que vous vous sentez des
affinités avec lui veut rassembler les
progressistes de droite et de gauche en
tout les galets les gens qui se
retrouvent de droite et de gauche sur ce
je crois pas inquiète
et oui il va pas du tout à cette
confusion à cette gauche
manière de dire voilà il ya plus de
différence c'est la différence c'est des
propositions qui sont pas les mêmes
on vient de parler de collèges
d'éducation oui bien peu propositions
sont à l'opposé de celle de najat
vallaud belkacem et c'est très bien
comme ça je le dis sereinement
je le dis de manière constructive ayons
ce débat et que les électeurs tranche
mais si tout se vaut plus rien ne se
vaut donc attention à cette façon de
mélanger de brouiller les lignes et de
dire qu'on va mettre avec soin tous les
progressistes sont que ça veut
absolument rien dire c'est de la soupe
c'est la soupe la politique a besoin de
clarté
l'avocat français dresse au pain pour
l'instant tout ce que j'entends oui
c'est de la soupe c'est quelque chose
qui est pas lisible qui est pas clair
puis comment est ce qu'on peut proposer
des choses tout en étant comptable la
situation d'edf
la situation de la sncf qui sont
catastrophiques c'est bien lui le
économiques irresponsables
il ya eu des centaines de milliers de
chômeurs en plus au cours de ce
quinquennat c'est bien le ministre
emmanuel macron 15 aussi ils entendaient
pour l'internât il a engagé ces
marcheurs sur la quête du diagnostic de
la france est un gage de diagnostic
il engage ces marcheurs où il le
souhaite mais je regarde le bilan des
entreprises publiques en mauvais état
des centaines de milliers de chômeurs en
plus et des augmentations d'impôts
absolument massives décidées dans les
premiers temps du quinquennat alors
qu'il était l'un des plus proches
collaborateurs n'est pas laisser voler
ses piques un thème du renouveau sous le
renouveau ne m'appartient pas en
particulier mais peut-être que cette
année je dis simplement leurs yeux ce
n'est pas la soupe ce n'est pas la
confusion c'est la clarté des
propositions la clarté de la méthode
politique et la clarté de ses alliances
politiques aussi très bien alors on va
parler de votre renouveau celui que vous
cherchez à incarner bruno le maire avec
cette deuxième partie de l'émission
nadège plus jacques de la fp donc pas
nous rejoindre et cette question
on laboure la primaire dont vous êtes
le/la outsiders blocs telle en fait tous
renouveau on peut se poser la question
quand je regardais sur les sondages
actuels à vous les regardez on écoute
d'abord une question notre confrère
david revaud d'alonnes du monde pour lui
vous êtes en fait et pour le reste est
le troisième homme
je ne prends pas une victoire de bruno
le maire ce qui est certain en tout cas
c'est qu'il a proposé une offre un petit
peu différente un petit peu nouvelle l'a
fondée sur l'innovation le
renouvellement et ça a plutôt marché je
dirais plutôt que le maire il sera le
monde pour des primaires de la droite
c'est à dire le troisième homme
il ferait un score sans doute très
important enfin assez important on sera
quand même largement derrière juppé et
sarkozy en croire les sondages mais il
sera en tout cas un élément déterminant
dans le deuxième tour il sera sans doute
le faiseur de roi selon qu'il se range
derrière juppé ou derrière sarkozy ça
peut évidemment faire basculer le
deuxième tour pensons au jour mentionné
mer alors on vient d'entendre notre
confrère du monde qui vous pour parra
monsieur brou tout bourse est un
compliment c'est pas un compliment
comment vous prenez ça je sais pas où
ils allaient pêcher cette ressemblance
mais il avait dû sacrément bois avant de
dire des propos pareils
moi je suis stupéfait du conservatisme
des observateurs alors voilà les choses
comme ça il ya deux favoris puis yann
outsider les outsiders à vos questions à
rester outsider
bien sûr mais moi je vais vous dire je
viendrai sincèrement jacques je veux
dire très sincèrement moi je suis
persuadé que nous allons gagner avec
toutes mes équipes
je pense que nous allons bouleverser jeu
politique je pense qu'il y en a ras le
bol d'entendre tous ces observateurs
alors je dis danger le troisième doit
rester troisième homme qu'on est faiseur
de roi on veut m'enfermer dans un rôle
dans lequel je n'ai bien juste avant
j'ai une question pour vous alors il ya
un peu plus de cinq mois encore juste à
la primaire qu'est ce qu'ils auraient la
qualité quelle est la qualité qui vous
distingue de tous vos confrères enfin
vous confrères par des concurrents ont
traversé heures c'est nous qui avons dès
lors qu'on va dire concurrents qu'elle
la qualité si vous n'avez une à nous
citer qu'est ce qui vous distingue
l'énergie mais aussi son énergique
neininger nicolas sarkozy finira rouge
pour gagner l'honnêteté l'honnêteté dans
ce que je
pause mais ça ça vous dit m je propose
un projet où monsieur je ne propose un
projet je n'ai pas proposé un projet en
2007 que je n'ai pas appliquée je tiens
toujours la même ligne et je tiens les
mêmes convictions j pas une chose et une
autre en fonction des personnes que j'ai
en face de moi je vais être obligé de
faire les sous titres je répond
sincèrement j'aurais pas sincèrement à
nadège l'honnêteté dans mon engagement
politique dans les convictions que j'ai
toujours défendues qui sont les mêmes
dans cette façon de dire oui moi je n'ai
jamais été présent la république ni
premier ministre n'est pas gouverné le
pays et je pense qu'il est temps de pays
passe à autre chose
les gouvernements quand même je n'ai
jamais gouverner le pays je peux vous
apprendre comment ça marche en france et
le premier ministre et le président de
la république qui dirige et j'ai envie
de dire aux observateurs à ceux qui
doutent à ceux qui sont résignés et ce
qu'ils voient là c'est le troisième
homme le faiseur de roi le montebourg de
droite
non c'est possible que le renouveau
gagne c'est possible que ça change enfin
c'est possible que pour une fois en
france on donne sa chance à du sang neuf
plutôt que de reprendre ceux qui sont
depuis 30 ans ou 40 ans dans la vie
politique française est dans les cinq
mois de campagne qui viennent à ses
voûtes les seconds nadège plus jacques
toutes les minutes de la campagne 15
jours je vais trouver aux français que
ce qu'ils croient simplement souhaitable
n'est pas que souhaitable c'est possible
et qu'on va y arriver tout seul c'est
possible justement leur avis que votre
projet le 2 juillet dernier monsieur
sarkozy qui est donc le président du
parti des républicains a rassemblé un
conseil national pour présenter le
projet du parti
vous n'étiez pas là les seuls absents
vous l'avez fait exprès on imagine je
leur absence la belge vous me connaissez
j'assume mes choix
bon alors je ne suis pas que je les fais
je les médias michel grossiord je ne me
sens pas engagé et je crois à la clarté
en politique je pense que là aussi les
français en ont ras le bol la confusion
des jeux politiciens des petites
alliance puis je suis là mais je suis
pas vraiment là je viens mais je viens
pas vraiment je prends la parole
maintenant moi ce n'est pas mon projet
donc je ne viens pas je respecte ce
projet je le stim qu'il ya un bon
travail qui a été fait il ya des choses
avec les coachs en désaccord complet
enfin je vais pas venir soutenir un
projet dont la première mesure c'est le
rétablissement de cumul des mandats en
enfin vous nous voyez venir
les français et de leur dire à vous
français vous allez changer mais nous
les responsables politiques est hors de
question qu'on change et même on va
rétablir le cumul des mandats ça regarde
bien les gars qu'est ce que vous leur
reprochez à tous les projets de vos
concurrents
d'abord c'est une question essentielle
le cumul des mandats
question symbolique commencer le
prochain quinquennat en disant nous
allons protéger à nouveau les élus et
rétablir le cumul des mandats je pense
que celle inverse ce qu'attendent les
français et celle un verre de scotch à
jean ferrat vitesse il ya si j'ose dire
et ceux qui sont pour le rétablissement
du cumul donc les sarkozystes monsieur
sarkozy en tête ne disent pas on va
protéger les nôtres ils disent il vaut
mieux avoir un pied dedans et un pied
dehors quand on fait de la politique
autrement dit quand on est parlementaire
c'est bien aussi d'avoir un pied à
l'étrier sur place ce niveau là haut sur
le terrain
sur le terrain ce n'est pas sur le
terrain quand on n'est pas le facteur
n'est pas sur le terrain c'est une drôle
de conception du parlementaire le député
il est élu au suffrage universel direct
par des citoyens et d'en contacter que
ses citoyens
tous ces arguments sont des prétextes
des prétextes pour maintenir son pouvoir
pour maintenir les baronnies pour
maintenant les fiefs moi je ne crois pas
au cumul des mandats je pense qu'il faut
limiter le nombre de mandats dans le
temps des députés des sénateurs
je pense qu'il facture et venir dans
deux députés du président du président
réduire le nombre de sénateurs est
obligé tous nos hauts fonctionnaires qui
font de la politique a démissionné de la
fonction publique quant à votre question
quelle est la différence
la différence c'est que moi je n'ai
jamais présenté de projet aux français
en 2007
il ya un très beau projet qui était
présenté aux français le drame c'est
qu'il n'a pas été appliquée l'une des
premières mesures c'était la tva sociale
au bout de trois semaines après
l'élection présidentielle de 2007
exit la tva sociale la deuxième mesure
c'était le contrat de travail unique à
bout de deux mois
exit le contaminer à l'ocl l'arrêter il
là et l'a fait à la fin de son
quinquennat au mieux quand on propose
quelque chose au but le faire au début
parce que sinon quand on le fait à la
fin ils risen battu de pas pouvoir
l'appliquer
c'est ce qui s'est passé va vous avez
bien vu c'est sarkozy là aussi toutes
les explications possibles ce que je
constate c'est qu'il ya eu une déception
que le projet n'a pas été appliquée eh
ben mon engagement c'est justement de
tenir parole sur le projet qu'on vous
dise mais vous avez participé voit ce
gouvernement
si vous n'étiez pas content si vous
n'étiez pas d'accord avec le fait qu'on
est pas la tva dès le début je n'étais
pas content avec taille et elle est
partie j'ai fait mon travail de
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes en défendant le couple
franco-allemand à une époque où c'était
pas très à la mode de défendre le couple
franco allemand
je les fais parce que c'était ma
conviction j'ai été ensuite ministre
l'agriculture et j'ai défendu les
paysans le mieux que je pouvais je vous
dis pas que j'ai tout réussi a
certainement des choses que j'ai pas
bien fait je crois que les paysans ont
su qu'ils avaient avec moi quelqu'un qui
les aimait et qui les défendent est
c'était mon rôle j'ai joué mon rôle ni
plus ni moins à propos des candidats
je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle à travers la primaire je
vais déposer en septembre prochain un
contrat de mandat précis avec des
engagements des chiffres un calendrier
et je veux que ce contrat de mandat soit
appliqué à la lettre
et si je suis élu je mettrai en place à
la présidence de la république une
équipe dont la seule responsabilité sera
de vérifier que ce contrat de mandat est
appliqué pour tenir parole
parce que les français en ont assez
qu'on ne tiennent pas parole qu'on fasse
de grandes promesses choix vague choix
précise qu'ils sont jamais appliquées
que ça aboutit à un divorce complet
entre les français et leurs responsables
politiques et que je pense que dans une
démocratie il n'y a rien de pire que
d'avoir ce divorce est très mordant à
vous écouter on a l'impression que
nicolas sarkozy par nature est
disqualifié est ce que nous verrons mais
hélas un bilan donc il ne peut plus
revenir nicher les brochures c'est
important de présenter les choses
clairement aux français c'est un premier
oui mais je pense que ça te fait faire
des choses à dire sur alain juppé alors
du même tonneau
il ya des différences dans nos projets
oui des différences importantes
alain juppé propose de faire un mandat
unique système ses arguments phares il
nous dit voilà je ferai un mandat unique
c'est l'assurance que je ferai les
choses
je crois au contraire que le quinquennat
unique c'est une impasse que ça conduira
à un président faible et qu un président
faible ne peut pas faire de grand chose
parce que le président qui m'accueille
monsieur le maire big up pour guerre les
sondages n'empêche que c'est quand même
sarkozy et juppé ou juppé sarkozy qui
arrive qui sont carrément premier bien
au sein de la neige plus jacques à cinq
mois de l'échéance et je vais montrer
aux français pendant toute cette
campagne qui l'a même pas encore
commencé
car la campagne officielle commence le
21 septembre
renouveau est possible que j'aie une
méthode de gouvernement qui est
différente que j'ai pris des engagements
qui seront précis dans ce contrat de
mandat que j'ai mis en place une méthode
politique pour garantir la mise en
oeuvre de ce contrat de mandat que je
procéderai d'abord par référendum sur le
renouvellement de la classe politique
dès juin 2010 est qu'ensuite il y aura
des ordonnances entre juillet et
septembre 2010 est pour aller vite pour
aller loin pour aller fort pour tenir
parole que je retourne au moins une
équipe qui sera resserrée ans c'est à
dire que vous ne venez pas leur avis et
au parlement s'exhale un tournant si le
parlement vote quand même puisqu'ils
votent la loi d'habilitation dessus
parlement fait des annonces il faut
aller vite il faut aller vite et
j'assume pour restaurer au roi parce
qu'il va y avoir des élections
législatives je ne pense moi je ne m'en
rends personnes entraient à neige plus
chaque jeudi les choses à l'avancé
explique clairement ce que je vais faire
je pense qu'il faut restaurer l'autorité
de l'état
libérés les capacités de production de
nos entrepreneurs restaurer la
solidarité la place du social qui a
dévoré la solidarité il faut le faire
vite si vous le faites pas rapidement
dans vous retrouver en situation de 2007
vous venez de le dire vous même la tva
sociale comme elle n'a pas été fait en
2007 on a essayé de la faire en 2012 au
bout du compte on n'a pas fait du tout
c'est ça qu'on veut
moi je veux le contraire je crois que ma
situation et notre pays il faudra aller
vite aller loin à l'effort pour savoir
un mandat clair dire les choses
simplement comme je le fais aujourd'hui
puis comparer les offres politiques pour
voir les différences et que les français
puissent juger en connaissance de cause
moi je me pose est maintenant une autre
question alors vous êtes une dizaine
pour la sambre comprend à peu près un
point aux merveilleuses je crois ou 12
même match
enfin tous en tous les cas non pas leur
parrainage il ya en particulier nathalie
kosciusko morizet et nadine morano qui
ont du mal à voir leurs parrainages
visiblement est une primaire sans femmes
c'est possible ça ce serait plus que
dommage et je pense que ce serait le
signal que voilà nous ne sommes pas
arrivés dans notre famille politique
justement à renouveler garantir la
parité à avoir suffisamment nouveaux
visages pense que c'est un concept des
check point de faire une politique
oui quand je vous dis dès lors paris n'a
jamais aidé sur veut dire quoi que je
bave rémois
je crois pas je ne crois pas à ces
manipulations politiques c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe je ne rentre dans
aucune de ces cuisines politique aucune
mais je pense que ce serait pour ma
famille politique
la vois aucune femme à la primaire un
vrai constat d'échec nathalie kosciusko
morizet estime que le jeu en fait est
déloyal aujourd'hui dans cette course
aux parrainages et même dans
l'organisation de la primaire on l'est
on y écoute par exemple sur les
adhérents le sujet c'est de réussir à y
toucher
réussir à les toucher alors qu'un
certain nombre de candidats ont
manifestement le fichier des adhérents
peuvent leur mêlée ce qui n'est pas le
cas de tout le monde
réussir à les toucher alors qu'ils sont
pas informés qu'ils peuvent parrainer
madame marion c'est valable pour moi une
rumeur ce que vous dites cela tous les
candidats à la candidature
sauf qu'il ya des candidats qui ont eu
plus accès au fichier qu'à d'autres
aujourd'hui des adhérents qui ont été
ceux adhérents depuis seulement trois
semaines et qui reçoivent des mails les
invitant à parrainer nicolas sarkozy qui
n'est pas encore candidat alors est-ce
que la primaire est faussée avec
l'extrait audio fichiers notamment
c'est difficile pour tout le monde les
parrainages c'est difficile pour tout le
monde ça a été difficile pour moi j'y ai
consacré un temps avec mes équipes et je
rends hommage à mes équipes absolument
considérable mais pour avoir ces
parrainages
il faut voir un projet qui puisse
mériter et susciter le soutien des
parents nathalie kosciusko morizet n'a
peut-être pas je souhaite le métallique
kosciusko morizet soit candidate dit
simplement que chacun est face à ses
responsabilités
les parages trop les parrainages de 150
élus et 2500 adhérents
est ce qu'on a mis la barre trop haut on
peut pas dire tout et son contraire à
cotonou dit à trop de candidats et après
on nous dit la barrière est trop haute
parfois elle savoir
moi j'estime que la barrière a été fixé
par notre famille politique que c'est
quelque chose qui est juste et
nécessaire pour éviter la dispersion des
candidats après moi je souhaite bonne
chance à nathalie kosciusko morizet je
souhaite sincèrement qu'elle puisse être
candidat très bonne chance à nadine
morano
j'espère qu'il y aura des candidates
féminines à cette primaire je souhaite
vraiment au plus profond de moi même et
je crois que si ça n'était pas le cas ce
sera vraiment la preuve que la famille
politique a du mal à se renouveler
il reste encore un sacré boulot à faire
alors la déclaration de candidature de
monsieur sarkozy balaie attendue vers la
fin du mois d'août ou plus exactement
25 août au plus tard c'est la date
couperet il a raison de ce d'attendre le
dernier moment avant famille à côté de
pas sur moi pour aller commenté des
campagnes d autres déjà suffisamment à
faire avec ma propre campagne
voyez bien vous me dites vous même il
faut que je passe d' outsider à gagnant
avec mes équipes etc mais parlementaires
et tous ceux qui me soutiennent partout
à travers la france c'est notre seule
ambition apporter cette générosité cet
enthousiasme pour montrer que le
renouveau est possible et que ce n'est
pas comme le dit david revault
d'allonnes voilà ça y est il est lui
déjà le résultat c'est très bien d'être
aussi clair et aussi net que les
journalistes leçon pourquoi les
journalistes seraient la liberté de
parole ne fallait responsables
politiques lui vous donne cinq mois à
l'avancé le résultat la primaire le
maire sera montebourg il fera un gros
score on n'en attendait pas un gros
score un assez gros score et c'est quoi
il est les électeurs à lui tout seul de
tous les électeurs de la droite du sang
de tous ses sympathisants qui ne veulent
plus de françois hollande
moi je crois au peuple français je crois
sa capacité de révolte
je crois à sa volonté de tourner la page
je crois sa volonté d'inventer quelque
chose est de reconstruire quelque chose
de nouveau et de 9 pour la france vous
verrez la surprise que les électeurs
réserveront les 20 et 27 novembre
je le sens dans tous les déplacements
que je fais alors les français ont hâte
axe de passer à autre chose
il ya quelques jours nicolas sarkozy
fait comparer aux joueurs de foot
olivier giroud 1
il est critiqué quand il est moins bon
mais il se redresse il se tient droit il
s'est comparé à jour vous vous comparez
acquis dans l'équipe de france arnaud
lemaire je suis fou dire je n'aurai pas
la prétention de nous comparer à aucun
des joueurs de l'équipe de france
j'aimerais bien avoir leur tonus leur
dynamisme leur capacité à tenir 90
minutes sur un terrain si on peu
d'énergie à me donner je suis preneur je
pense que d'énergie ça compte beaucoup
en politique mais j'aurais pas c'est la
suffisance dont consacré un jeu a donc
comparé à un joueur de foot tel que j'ai
vu jouer à l'euro 2016 si vous souhaitez
simplement vous comparez à vos
concurrents de la primaire apparaît
justement je ne me compare pas j'avance
jeudi avec quoi je suis d'accord avec
moi je suis en désaccord
j'ai des relations ont toujours été
parfaitement sereine et avec nicolas
sarkozy élèves avec alain juppé mais ce
qu'est une compétition qu'il y à un
combat électoral et que ce combat
électoral
si dell gagné mais je remue le couteau
dans la plaie la bannière j'ai l'air de
dire qu'on allait peut-être pas gagné je
ne sais pas moi je ne sais pas qui va
gagner le plus breton que veut pas ou
alors si sarkozy françois bayrou a déjà
prévu et prévenu pardon et ben moi
j'irai j'irai parce que je veux pas que
ce soit lui
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je prends
un engagement sur ce sujet oui j'ai la
conviction que nous pouvons tous
ensemble gagner cette primaire et je
pense qu'on peut pas être candidat à la
primaire sans dire dès le départ à tous
les électeurs quel que soit le vainqueur
je soutiendrai quel que soit le
vainqueur je ne soutiendrai parce que le
plus important c'est que nous battions
françois hollande s'est tous battus on
la gauche c'est qu'il y ait une alto et
françois bayrou justement s'il ya là il
pourrait vous empêcher empêcher cela je
pense que tous ceux qui se reconnaissent
dans nos valeurs dans nos idées qui
considère que le quinquennat de françois
hollande a été un vrai échec
j'aimerais que tous ces gens là se
disent mais dans le fond mettons-nous
d'ailleurs celui qui est le mieux placé
pour gagner de façon à garantir la ville
avant bayrou ça me parait où il est la
position la plus responsable
après on verra ce que fait françois
bayrou il a fait ces déclarations là on
attendra la fin du deuxième tour de la
primaire pour voir quelle position il
prendra on en est pas encore là
merci nadège ontolica françois bayrou
est opposé au système de la primaire il
estime en prenant notamment l'exemple
américain que cela porte ouverte aux
surenchères populistes notamment est ce
que vous allez vous préservez de cette
surenchère sur certaines thématiques par
exemple l'identité nationale sur
laquelle vous avez tenu des propos assez
fort ces dernières semaines moi je vois
pas de surenchère pour le bon bourgeois
un débat projet contre projet c'est très
bien comme ça ce sera un thème fort
louis était c'est un thème fort puisque
j'ai été repéré envie de dire par
nicolas sarkozy et je ne crois pas ce
thème de l'identité je pense que nos
réalités ça en forme d'identité c'est ea
mobile
je pense que ce qui fait la force de la
france et notre culture culture qui est
vivante qui bouge qui est mobile notre
culture c'est notre langue la langue
française que je me bats autant pas la
langue française c'est notre histoire
c'est d'où nous venons et quand on ne
connaît pas l'histoire de france on peut
pas inventer l'avenir de son pays
c'est toutes ces mémoires qui sont très
différentes nous avons tous une part
d'origine différente en ou parfois
d'origine étrangère mais s'est
rassemblée dans la culture française
dans nos principes républicains
il faut défendre
culture française bec et ongle cassé sa
nourrice dans lesquelles l ennemi
l'ennemi c'est tous ceux qui ne croient
plus dans la culture française ou ceux
qui renoncent tout ce qu'il abandonne
c'est quand on abandonne la langue
française qu'on respecte pas la culture
française c'est quand on veut juger un
ministre britannique a déclaré il ya
quelques jours que l'immigration massive
menaçait la grande-bretagne vos derrière
la même chose pour la france
je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui des
menaces qui pèsent effectivement sur la
culture française sur nos principes
républicains
l'islam politique je dis bien politique
est une menace pour notre culture
l'islam politique refuse l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes
l'islam politique bourré de rendre les
femmes invisibles la société française
c'est le contraire de ce que nous sommes
comme français l'islam politique
voudrait dire que les religions peuvent
imposer leurs règles à l'état il se
trouve qu'en france c'est l'état qui
impose les règles aux religions donc oui
un combat à mener contre l'islam
politique et ses intérêts de tous
notamment des citoyens de confession
musulmane
troisième partie de leur répertoire
merci encore nadège plus jack avec
vitaly la baisse de public sénat qui
arrivent pour parler donc défense
puisque vous venez d'affirmer un certain
nombre de positions fortes sur ce thème
là est également europe avec ce grand
malaise provoqué par l'ancien président
de la commission josé manuel barroso qui
est passé chez le banquier américain
goldman sachs la critique de jean
arthuis le président de la commission
des budgets au parlement européen élu
centriste si ceux qui constituent
l'élite et monsieur barroso avait une
responsabilité qui le mettait dans cette
élite
si les gens de l'élite n'ont pas un
minimum d'éthique personnelle alors en
effet il donne et donne une bien
singulière images et contribue à faire
monter l'exaspération des citoyens est
sans doute ce qu'on appelle le populisme
bonsoir mickaël szames fo saint michel
bauchar bono le maire josé manuel
barroso at il commis une faute contre
l'europe
oui faux pas contre l'europe l'a commis
une faute contre les principes les plus
élémentaires de la morale politique
le mélange des gens quand on était
président de la commission doit pas
travailler pour une banque dont on sait
qu'elle a falsifié les comptes grecs
alors même qu'on était responsable la
crise
c'est un principe élémentaire de dignité
politique
il a commis une faute il doit partir il
doit démissionner de cette fonction
aujourd'hui c'est à lui de voir quelle
conséquence ils en tireront vous me
demandez mon regard mon regard est très
simple josé manuel barroso a commis une
faute
si vous prenez des engagements si un
jour vous deviez quitter la politique
est ce que vous vous engagez à ne jamais
travailler pour une banque d'affaires
nous n'en sommes pas là mais je dois
dire que le contrairement à d'autres moi
j'ai jamais eu beaucoup d'appétence pour
la banque d'affaires ca métier que je
respecte et qui est très important
d'ailleurs pour financer notre économie
mais voilà c'est pas mon truc
moi je ne vois pas banquier d'affaires
d'autres questions en rapport avec
l'europe est on arrivé à la grande
bretagne avec le changement de premier
ministre david cameron a présidé
aujourd'hui sont gagnées conseil des
ministres et donc c'est theresa may qui
était jusque là ministre de l'intérieur
qui lui succède on l'écouté évoquait
justement le bric site et comment elle
va s'en arranger désormais le besoin
bien sûr et de négocier le meilleur
accord pour le royaume uni qui sort de
l'union européenne et l'établissement de
notre nouveau rôle dans le monde
brick 6 signifie briques site et nous en
ferons un succès vous comptez sur cette
nouvelle point ministre theresa may pour
régler ce problème du bric site ont péri
mode et d'accélérer maintenant tout cas
je lui souhaite bonne chance
déjà bien je rends hommage aussi à la
dignité démocratie britannique où quand
on a perdu
voilà david cameron en a tiré les
conséquences et il a trouvé un
successeur rapidement en plus est une
femme je vous ai fait plaisir de voir
une femme à la tête du de la grande
bretagne après des règles sont claires
la grande bretagne a fait un choix elle
sort de l'union européenne il faut en
tirer toutes les conséquences quand
j'entends dire avant du sein la supposée
pas avant 2010 est je pense qu'il faut
aller rapidement il faut avancer
là encore clairement quand je vois
certains dire il faut que la grande
bretagne puisse disposer du passeport
européen c'est à dire que dans grohl
pour installer ses banques et
établissements financiers en europe
comme si elle était encore un membre
d'une européenne s'agit c'est pas
possible je suis désolé c'est pas
possible
vous ne pouvez pas être en dehors de
l'europe avoir tous les avantages de la
construction européenne et aucun
désagrément c'est pas possible
et là dessus on doit être totalement
intransigeant avec nos amis britanniques
la grande bretagne est un grand pays
je souhaite qu'on maintienne des
coopération avec eux d'un certain nombre
de secteurs je pense en particulier à la
défense les règles du jeu sont claires
quand on sort on sort françois hollande
va amorcer une mini tournée de certains
pays européens pour essayer de rebooster
un petit peu le moteur européen at-il
encore cette capacité
aujourd'hui ce logo c'est son rôle je
vais pas critiquer le fait qu'il ait
fait la tournée des pays européens enfin
soyons clairs nous sommes apolitiques
une ronde à doha mais vous avez raison
moins d'un an nous sommes en juillet
2016 il reste dix mois jusqu'à
l'élection présidentielle
la vraie échéance et 2017 en 2017 vous
aurais je l'espère une nouvelle majorité
en france et un nouveau président de la
république vous aurez une majorité
consolidé en allemagne puisque les
élections législatives allemandes ont
lieu à l'automne 2010 est donc vous
aurez les deux principaux pays de
l'union européenne qui auront toute
légitimité pour refonder l'europe et
c'est en 2017 qu'il faudra peut-être
lancer les jeux référendum pour ou
contre l'union européenne certainement
pas ce qui peut être que j'exclus
totalement marc ayrault l'a dit être un
peu de temps totalement je ne veux
surtout pas de référendum pour ou contre
l'union européenne organise en 2010 est
gelé ça au front national
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on
refonde l'europe qu'on clarifie les
choses sur quatre questions essentielles
les institutions qui doit être plus
clair et moins bureaucratique les
frontières pour que l'europe ait des
frontières et disent maintenant
clairement la turquie qu'elle ne
rentrera pas dans l'union européenne
nos intérêts économiques pour défendre
nos intérêts économiques et pas ceux de
la chine ou des états unis et enfin
notre sécurité parce que je souhaite que
la france ne voit pas la seule à
augmenter son budget de défense mais que
les autres le fassent ça ces
négociations à mettre sur la table
elles prendront ensuite la forme d'un
nouveau traité ça prendra quelques
années ça va pas se faire du jour au
lendemain quand j'entends certains dire
on aura un nouveau traité d'ici la fin
et 2016 non c'est totalement irréaliste
ça prendra quelques années à la fin du
processus quand nous aurons arrêté
consultation indispensable de consulter
les français par ray faire de référendum
mais sur un projet positif parce que si
on veut effacer la blessure de 2005
effacer la blessure du nord où les
peuples français dit non mais petit
qu'on dit c'est pas grave vous dit non
on continue quand même pas donné la
parole aux français de redonner la
parole au peuple français et moi je fais
confiance au peuple français
peu lui présenter un nouveau projet et
le convaincre bono le maire vous avez
présenté hier votre programme pour la
défense dans un entretien à valeurs
actuelles le ministre la défense jean
yves le drian annonce le maintien d'une
opération sentinel travées ce sont tous
ces militaires que l'on voit un petit
peu partout dans la rue on va passer de
10 mille à 7000 est-ce suffisant selon
vous je pense que c'est déjà une bonne
décision de réduire le volume de
sentinelle sentinelle voir ce que c'est
pour les soldats c'est des gardes
statiques qui sont très éprouvante c'est
'circulez à paris dans d'autres grandes
villes avec à l'équipement qui est très
lourd s'être éloigné de sa famille
pendant des semaines et des semaines est
dur et très long et c'est de ne pas
avoir d'entraînement militaires alors
qu'ils se sont engagés pour être entré
le maintien de cette opération je
souhaite une évolution plus profonde que
ces deux brillants
ça veut dire une réduction non pas à
7000 mais à mon avis de l'ordre de 3000
à 5000
ça veut dire la suppression de toute
garde statique et uniquement du
déplacement mobile dans les villes
dessin animé très rarement sécurité des
français et ça veut dire trouver une
alternative
l'alternative ça peut être par exemple
l'utilisation de la réserve réserve de
la gendarmerie réserve militaire réserve
de la police pour qu'on puisse
progressivement déchargés nos soldats de
cette responsabilité là et qu'ils
puissent reprendre leur entraînement et
leurs missions essentielles qu'elle nous
protège et sur les théâtres d'opérations
extérieures le 26 juillet c'est la fin
de l'état d'urgence
est-ce que vous souhaiter qu'il soit
prolongé si c'est vraiment au
gouvernement de prendre cette décision
parce qu'ils ont de l'information je le
dirai beaucoup de simplicité que je n'ai
pas par définition donc que le
gouvernement assume ses responsabilités
moi j'ai soutenu et j'ai voté pour
l'état d'urgence quand le gouvernement
le proposait ce que j'estimais que
c'était nécessaire
on verra ce que nous propose le
gouvernement la fin du mois de juillet
vous souhaitez augmenter le budget de la
défense pour le porter à environ 2 % du
budget national
alain juppé a dit je veux aussi dire le
site
il ne sert à rien de promettre des
augmentations et réaliste vous étiez
réaliste c'est dommage peut être
ambitieux pour la france et ont
possiblement on peut tous être ambitieux
on affiche alors une eau à cette espèce
de résignation avoir des forces armées
qui n'ont ni les équipements ni les
hommes ni les technologies dont elles
ont besoin tout à la moindre problème
pas moi c'est dommage de ne pas voir que
tout autour de nous la russie se
réarment la chine se réarment notre
environnement immédiat et dangereux en
particulier au moyen-orient bien moi
j'en tire les conséquences et jeudi de
manière réaliste les responsables il est
temps d'en finir avec trente années on a
cessé de réduire les budgets et les
équipements de nos forces armées pour
leur donner enfin les moyens nous
protéger vous cherchez les différences
de fond avec alain juppé en voilà une
lui estime qu' il faut colmater les
brèches ici ou là et bien moi j'estime
qu'en matière de défense
au contraire il faut réinventer un
modèle d'armée qu'ils soient plus
efficaces
technologiquement plus avancés capable
de mieux nous protéger
quand nos armées sont fortes la nation
française est forte c'est mon ambition
est d'être à makala gp n'est pas assez
fort sur ce thème là sur le thème
régalien je l'entends dire que ça n'est
pas responsable ou pas réaliste de
proposer 2 % pour le budget militaire de
la nation française donc un geste votre
votre chance c'est dix ans enregistrant
que cette proposition est responsable
réaliste est nécessaire deux exemples
encore si vous le permettez est-ce qu'il
faut replacer le charles de gaulle
signe qu'il faut un deuxième porte
avions je vais vous dire pourquoi le
charles-de-gaulle va rentrer en arrêt
technique majeur son troisième arrêt
technique d'ici quelques temps il va
être immobilisé pendant une période de
dix-huit à vingt mois c'est à dire que
pendant 18 à 20 mois la france n'aura
pas de groupe aéronaval ne pourra pas
projeter sa puissance et faire les
démonstrations de force qui peuvent être
nécessaires
alors soit on a un groupe aéronaval soit
on en a pas on en a pas un qui est à
disposition uniquement quand le porte
avions n'est pas en réparation donc je
propose de lancer dès 2017
les travaux et les études la réalisation
d'un deuxième porte avions de façon à ce
que la france puisse disposer à tout
moment d'un groupe aéronaval qu'elle
puisse projeter en fonction de la
deuxième petite question bruno le maire
le service militaire nicolas sarkozy n
est laissé supposer qu'ils pourraient
recourir au référendum sur cette
question
l'hystérie favorable je le ferai pas et
ça va être serré devenir très
intéressant cette primaire parce qu'on
va voir quelle de vraies différences
il savait un vrai débat de fond
intéressant et je l'espère à la hauteur
des français des attentes des français
je ne consulterait pas les français par
référendum sur un service militaire je
ne rétablirait pas de service militaire
obligatoire parce que je considère que
les armées françaises
ne sont pas faites pour cela nous avons
fait un autre choix
en revanche je pense qu'on peut
développer davantage les services
militaires volontaires les services
militaires adaptés qui existe dans les
départements d'outre-mer j'ai vu à quel
point notamment dans l'île de la réunion
c'était des dispositifs et fiables et
récents pour les décrocheurs n'ont aucun
diplôme je ne suis pas favorable à des
dispositifs obligatoires
qu'est-ce qu'on veut deux jeunesses des
jeunes acadiens attendez vous vous êtes
décrocheurs c'est service militaire
obligatoire
vous avez réussi vous étiez de rupture
avec brit air chaud que c'est une
rupture d'égalité
je trouve que c'est une vraie rupture
d'égalité je pense que c'est service
militaire doivent rester sur la base du
volontariat pour que ce soit des jeunes
qui ont vraiment envie qu'il y aille
c'est comme ça qu'ils en tireront le
meilleur profit vous avez été très
sévère tout à l'heure pour deux
ministres du gouvernement najat vallaud
belkacem et marisol touraine que
diriez-vous du ministre de la défense
monsieur le drian qui adulent est
semble-t-il par ses troupes et qui est
également applaudi à droite pour son
action à la tête de l'armée française et
puis également pour son action de vrp
parce que jamais on n'a autant vendu
d'armes dans notre pays alors
globalement là pour lui ça sera pas un
zéro pointé un pour la ministre de
l'éducation nationale cei d'être honnête
dans mes jugements et sincère je
reconnais que jean yves le drian est un
mini ce qui est apprécié par les forces
armées et par vous même qui a fait du
bon boulot ou y reconnaissons le il a
fait du bon boulot
mon seul regret c'est que il est
conservé la présidence de la région au
bretagne
moi je trouve que notre dernier la
fonction oui mais je trouve que c'est là
aussi un mélange des gens et qui serait
un ministre de la défense encore plus
apprécier encore plus respectable s'il
avait renoncé à son poste de président
de la région bretagne
on va rester sur les questions de
défense et de renseignement puisque
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur
fait connaître sa réponse aux 39
propositions de la commission denquête
la semaine dernière sur les attentats
terrible du 13 novembre georges fenech
il ya quelques jours s'indigner c'était
la semaine dernière ils s'écoutent il
s'indignait en ces termes écouter de la
réponse faite dans l'immédiat par le
ministre de l'intérieur ni à nous dire
que ce que nous proposons c'est du poum
pudding j'imagine enfin vous c'est à
dire pour ajouter au millefeuille vous
compliqué c'est une injure c'est une
injure à notre travail c'est un mépris
c'est une arrogance c'est une suffisant
je le dis comme je le pense ballack est
venue confirme dans une lettre qu'il n'y
aura pas la création de cette fameuse
agence nationale de sécurité qui
permettrait de rassembler un petit peu
toutes ses agences de renseignement est
ce une erreur dont je salue le travail
qui a été fait par georges fenech
la mission locale parle mais il se
trouve qu'il a fait un très bon travail
et que ça mérite mieux effectivement
qu'un revers de main de la part du
ministre intérieur
même si mini de l'intérieur a nuancé un
petit peu quand même mais la question se
pose est-ce qu'elle rêverait ordination
dans les services de renseignement on
peut améliorer encore cette coordination
oui je pense que c'est possible
d'améliorer encore la coordination vous
savez pas vraiment également en service
est-ce que ça doit prendre
nécessairement la forme d'une agence je
n'en suis pas forcément convaincu mais
on peut améliorer encore la coordination
et donc je trouve que ça mérite mieux ce
travail remarquable qui a été fait par
georges fenech que un mépris un revers
de la main pour être une base de travail
pour vous ça peut être une base de
travail résume bien à 15,9 qui est jugés
méprisants par georges fenech c'est
votre avis ne rentrons pas dans ces
quelques actifs sur les uns sur les
autres
moi je juge le fonds et vous voyez bien
que que ce soit sur mes candidats à la
primaire sur mes adversaires de gauche
j'essaie juste de voir ce qu'ils font
qu'elles sont le résultat est de juger à
partir de là après on est d'accord on
n'est pas d'accord sur les sujets de
fond et c'est les français qui tranchent
quel est votre programme jusqu'à la
primaire vous avez encore des rendez
vous thématiques bien sûr avec les
français est ce que vous allez écrire un
livre
non vous devez vivre j'aimerais bien
mais le temps me manquerait donc que je
vais finir le mode juillet d'abord en
allant parler un peu de culture dans le
sud de la france
ensuite prendre des vacances l'été
arrivant dans quinze jours puis après je
ferai du 16 août au 28 août la tournée
des plages plage la tournée des plages
sud est mais oui ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont présents à ce moment là
donc je veux discuter avec eux leur
présenter mon projet je sais le chemin
qu'il reste à parcourir chèque le plus
dur reste à faire pour gagner le plus
dur reste à faire le plus dur c'est de
convaincre chaque électeur chaque
français que le renouveau est possible
que c'est entre leurs mains que ça ne
dépendra que deux et donc il faut pas
perdre son temps et utiliser aussi l'été
pour les convaincre chacun alors donc
voilà il y aura des animations bruno le
maire sur les plages cet été
je vous dis pas que je serai en maillot
et en tomber mais presque reste qu'à
écouter voilà on a noté le rendez vous
merci beaucoup à bono le maire avec nous
aujourd'hui pour cette dernière émission
de la saison merci mais quand on se
retrouve donc dès la mi-septembre sur
public sénat bonsoir à tous et à très
vite est excellente et et à tous